let's talk a little bit about why
they're doing this first i want to show
you the story we have it from nbc5
chicago this is actually from january
illinois congresswoman uh i'm not going
to i'm not going to repeat what you said
but she uh she said
that there was one thing
that the nazis did that she think they
understood properly i'll make sure i
paraphrase i'll paraphrase this because
i'm not going to she said i'm not going
to i'm not going to read it you can see
it on the screen
um this congresswoman was heavily
criticized for essentially making a
statement that the nazis were were
effective in a certain way and that was
targeting children nbc says a newly
sworn in congress congresswoman from
southern illinois quoted adolf hitler as
she spoke outside the us capitol saying
the nazi leader
she believed
got one thing correct
mary miller was speaking at a rally in
dc when a twitter user posted the video
tuesday showing a portion of her speech
what she was trying to say was that one
of the goals of the nazis was to target
children so that they could erase the
the world view of the parents
and through that
in about 20 years they won right and
they took over let me actually show you
this we have this um
this article from
mssu.edu
they say
hitler's first act of business after the
election was the revamping of the german
education system to to include extensive
military training as well as
anti-semitic propaganda he then could
use this brainwashing of the children
against rebellious parents quote when an
opponent declares i will not come over
to your side he said in november 1933
speech i will calmly say your child
belongs to us already what are you you
will pass on your descendants however
now stand in the new camp in a short
time they will know nothing else about
this new community
and there you go right that's exactly
what they're doing now now i want to i
want to let you know why i'm uh i'm
pessimistic
you know they tried to censor hitler it
didn't work
in germany there were efforts to he was
imprisoned you know he was he was
censored
it didn't work he was able to
indoctrinate people and children
and
gained power and became the fuhrer so
interestingly we see all of these these
these states saying they're going to ban
critical race theory teachings and i
don't know if it will work telling a
teacher they can't teach this does that
mean the teachers are also going to be
like well i can't quote anymore are they
going to be like don't tell anyone
they're doubling down i mean that's what
the nea resolution is about it's
basically saying we're going to fight
this and we're going to make sure that
we teach it and you know as you were
reading that quote i was just thinking
back to again why i know that
this is something that everybody's got
to care about because
when i was fighting the issue of how
extremism came into my muslim community
all i had to do is go back to this word
that everybody's learned now right the
madrasa the religious school that's
where they grab the kid they bring them
in they indoctrinate them in our modern
day it was the saudi government that was
creating those schools in pakistan
throughout the middle east and that's
who that's what created our taliban our
jihadis of today
and now
this has been our fight in our might in
that community against an ideology and
we have made progress like i want you to
actually have hope because
we do have rights in this country we're
taking them to court
in fairfax county virginia we've sued
the school district for racial
discrimination because they are
targeting asians and explicitly doing so
um
we have parents who are there's i i was
it was awesome i love it i saw not my
idea as an exhibit in a lawsuit in out
of illinois nice you know this is this
is what we have to do because parents do
have rights we have right to privacy we
have you know your kid doesn't have to
explain everything about their gender
their race their sexuality we have a
right to information about the
curriculum um so this is this yeah we
can do it this book is is is amazingly
terrifying and crazy
so this is the book not my idea you
mentioned a book about whiteness so so
this was being taught to children you
said it is yep pennsylvania
so i i just opened up to one of you one
of your notes
and there's one page it says connecting
means opening and opening sometimes
feels our cars parked over here love
like breaking the next page um mom i
don't feel good uh oh should i pull over
says the mom
in the next page let me turn the page
i need to know what's going on
what are you talking about that's the
mother saying that why didn't anyone
teach me real history i do see color i
see yours mine and everybody's you can't
hide what's right in front of me
this is a child yelling i know what that
poli i know
what that police officer did was wrong
this is the child speaking of the mother
go with your instincts on this one
racial justice is possible okay jeez you
don't have to yell this is a book
explaining to a child why to argue with
your parents what's really fascinating
to me is how it's the opposite of of
christianity yeah honor their father and
their mother this one is the mom's like
what are you talking about i i don't
understand no mom you're wrong i know
what really happened yes and which is
this constant theme i'm so glad you
picked up on that page because that's
the theme that the kid knows better and
the kid is now taught by the teacher
who's going to teach them better than
their ignorant parents now here's where
it all comes together because sure i
referenced this uh educational piece
about adolf hitler and what he did to
children the communists did the same
thing they wanted the children snitching
on their parents yes so the parents
would be sitting there reading the paper
saying ah stalin all right turn the page
and go oh and then run to school my dad
said this and then the dad's in the
gulag right right and
so many of the parents that are in my
school that my son just graduated from
they survived the cultural revolution
and so they said they watched kids
snitch on their parents oh yeah and they
see from they have traumatic memories
back to that experience so i just
searched it again it was 1966 to 1976
that the culture of revolution happened
maoism then of course continued and
continued has continued its tyranny but
this is what we're getting it's this
book's really uh quite an amazing piece
of propaganda for children
in an earlier segment the little girl is
reading and it says in the united states
of america white people have committed
outrageous crimes against black people
for 400 years
all along every step of the way people
who love justice and love each other
have been fighting back you know they
take a morsel of truth right this
history this country has its bad history
as do most countries i mean look at look
at the history of any european nation
see the horrible things they did and
especially but i would say any nation
right india
has had tyranny by its own people af
countries in africa have had tears the
word america what was it the word slave
comes from slav
now here's what's fascinating what this
book is doing is it's outlining what
children should do after they've been
indoctrinated by the cult mem the cult
of worshipers at these schools
after they start teaching the children
these things and and and and demonizing
the country demonizing their own parents
the book then goes on to explain how the
child should yell at their parents about
how they were lied to how they don't
feel good how they do see color yeah
they're going to indoctrinate your kids
and then use books like this so the kids
have a game
they're indoctrinated not only on what
to believe but how to react to their
parents when their parents challenge
them yeah and what they basically are
doing like for example in um a st louis
uh suburb
the curriculum design person literally
wrote a memo to the other teachers
saying
this is the stuff that you should hide
from the curriculum wow online yeah wow
yeah this is this book you got you
should have taken a day right i mean
look at it yeah first pages when
grown-ups tried to hide scary things
from kids oh no not again what mom what
not again
she says
who is that with their hands up why is
that policeman screaming at him right as
if to imply that parents secretly know
what's going on but don't tell their
children right and and it's always a
conspiracy of silence that the parents
are perpetuating that the teacher now
will break and of course there are
teachers we're getting leaks from
teachers all over the country we have
teachers who are just so afraid of
speaking up
one great
one awful example
portland oregon suburb beaverton
we got a leak from a teacher that they
had an equity seminar and at the equity
seminar one of their equity warriors
who's a teacher told the others that
they had to go along with all of this
anti-racism
or evolve and evolve or dissolve
lose their jobs
they should
well walk away stop doing it yes that's
a it's such a tragedy you know that
there are people of conscience who
really do not believe in any of this and
right now their livelihood is on the
line
yeah we got a dark future heading
towards us no we do not because we are
fighting back that's what i want to tell
you i am literally standing here like
sitting here the embodiment of a mom who
just captures you know the uh stories
from morning till night we do it we are
thousands of parents you know
those school board meetings that you're
seeing it's happening because courage is
contagious yes
courage is contagious let's hope bannon
was correct when the parents see this
stuff they will step up and yell out
they are yelling out but but i will say
there are a lot of people online
they say they're scared to use their
real names they're scared to use their
actual photos they're scared to speak up
at work because they'll lose their jobs
people respond to me saying tim you
don't have kids you have no idea what
it's like i'm not going to risk my
family over this right i know and my
response is
but you are when you're when your little
girl comes home calling you the bigot in
the monster when she turns 16 and she's
reading all of the stuff and she says
you're evil you're evil and nasty and
runs away and hates your guts when your
child grows up grows up in a world being
told that they're evil in an oppressor
why would you sacrifice the the the
world that your children are going to be
inheriting but i get it i suppose people
are scared and would rather put food on
the table and have their kid grow up in
a goo log for resisting than to actually
stand up now
and fight hard to to to succeed i get it
it must be scary i'm not going to
pretend like i know what it's like to
have kids but i can certainly tell you
you've got a stack of books how many
books is this 15. i know and we left
books back yeah
yeah there's a whole bunch of them but
the thing is i want to just tell you
that
the
parents are figuring out ways you know
what's happening is they are setting up
instagram pages like woke at da da
school fill in the blank and exposing
what's happening they're sending us
secret tips you know with and they do
check the box that they want to be
anonymous but they're getting the
information out the documentation i
wouldn't i wouldn't know about not my
idea except that a mom wrote to us about
it you know and said this is messed up
so that's where like a single
whistleblower right then allows us to
share it with the world and that's where
every single parent i think has so much
uh
possibility of power whether or not you
know they take the big risks because
there are some people who will take more
risks than others and can
but but but i think everybody's got a
role so so do you want to tell people
your site where people can send this
stuff
yeah please go to defendinged.org
and um and it's really simple form folks
can fill it out and we have moms working
around the clock chasing down these tips
awesome thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to see the full show come back
to this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you